Bitte schön. Guten Abend. Guten Abend. Ich heiße Mohammed Hamidi. Ich bin auf dieser
Station als Assistant Ars Tittig und wurde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen.
Sind Sie einverstanden? Ja, Hauptsache, jemand guckt nach mir.
Ja, zuerst stelle ich ein paar allgemeine Frage ganz schnell und dann kommen wir
zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Ist es normal? Ja, klar. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Manfred Simon. Manfred? Manfred, das ist mein Vornamen.
Der Familie Name ist Simon. S-B-M-O-N.
Okay, einfach auf Nachname. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 74.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 25. April 1948.
Genau. Simon, wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 178.
178. Genau. Ja, 178. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
89 kg. 89 kg. Genau.
Okay, Simon, wie können ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich fühle mich seit langer Zeit sehr schlecht und schlapp.
Ich habe heftigen Husten und beim Husten kommt auch so blutige Schleim raus.
Das finde ich so ein bisschen beängstigend. Husten und mit Auswurf.
Genau. Und der Auswurf mit Blut. Genau.
Und ich bin ganz müde. Und der Farbe ist auswurfs?
Ja, der ist so ein bisschen rosa, aber eigentlich ist das weiße Zeug.
Das ist nicht eilig. Nicht eilig?
Ungefähr gelbisch, grünisch.
Wenig gelb oder grün? Weißlich, ja. Weißlich.
Und seit wann haben diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das geht schon einige Monate.
Und es wird aber jetzt irgendwie immer schlechter.
Den Husten habe ich schon vier Jahre.
Da habe ich immer gesagt, ach, ist nicht so schlimm.
Ja, ein bisschen Husten. Aber seit das jetzt losgegangen ist.
Ich verstehe, die Husten seit vier Jahren, ungefähr vier Jahren.
Ja, und seit einem Monat.
Seit drei Monaten ist es schlimmer geworden.
Ja, und seit drei Monaten immer schlimmer geworden.
Genau. Und wenn ich jetzt die Treppe hochlaufe, dann fühle ich mich so schlapp.
Bei laufend.
Mein Herz, wenn ich mit der Treppe hochlaufe.
Und bei schnell laufen und bei Treppen steigen.
Ja, ich lauf nicht schnell.
Bei Treppen muss ich manchmal hochlaufen.
Ja, bei Treppen einsteigen, schlechter.
Aufsteigen.
Da kriege ich keine Luft.
Und da habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass mein Herz ganz doll klopft.
Okay, und das atmet auch zusammen mit Husten seit drei Monaten.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Zusammen, Atemnot und Husten.
Genau.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen in dem Brust?
Ja, ich habe schon ein bisschen Schmerzen in der Brust.
Beim Brusten und ja.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leichten und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen.
Ich kann dir aushalten, die Schmerzen.
Ich bin nicht so empfindlich.
Vielleicht sind die bei 5 ungefähr.
Okay.
Und Skala sieht sich mehr.
Ja, die Schmerzen sind schon in letzter Zeit ein bisschen mehr geworden.
Ja, okay.
Streiten Sie die Schmerzen irgendwo hin?
Nein, nein, ich habe so das Gefühl, da wo ich atme, da tut es weh.
Nur beim Atmen.
Schmerzen nur bei Husten.
Bei Husten.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber glaube ich nicht.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich lieb.
Und Schuttebrust?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht gehabt.
Okay.
Herr Simon, schlafen Sie Fleisch oder sollten Sie ein paar Kisten benutzen?
Ja, manchmal nehme ich mir ein zweites Kissen, damit ich besser abbrusten kann.
Aber viel Unterschied macht es nicht.
Sind Ihre Beine geschworen?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Dicker als normal?
Glaube nicht.
Nein, nicht.
Problem mit dem Herz.
Zum Beispiel Herzschlöpfer.
Ja, wie gesagt, nur wenn ich jetzt versuche, schnell die Treppe hochzugehen
oder überhaupt die Treppe zu laufen.
Da merke ich das mal, dass ich ein bisschen Herz klopfen kriege, aber normalerweise nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang?
Ja, mit dem Stuhlgang eigentlich nicht.
Nacht muss ich ein paar Mal raus auf die Toilette.
Das passiert schon mal.
Noch einmal bitte, ich hatte auch ein kurzes Problem.
Stuhlgang, keine Probleme.
Aber ich muss manchmal nachts auf die Toilette gehen zum Wasserlassen.
Was ist das Problem bei Wasserlassen?
Dass ich nachts aufwache und auf die Toilette gehe.
Wie viel Mal?
Ja, meistens einmal in der Nacht, manchmal auch zweimal, aber eher einmal in der Nacht.
Dann haben Sie Probleme bei Prostata?
Ja, das ist seit zehn Jahren bekannt, dass die Prostata ein bisschen vergrößert ist.
Ist Ihnen schwindelisch?
Nein.
Ist Ihnen obel oder hatten Sie Erbrechen?
Nein, nein, nein, ich muss nur.
Herr Simon, leiden Sie chronische oder vor Krankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck,
Zuckerkrankheit, Schilddoseprobleme?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, die Prostata ist vergrößert.
Ja, bis auf Prostata?
Ja, außerdem habe ich auch noch hohen Blutdruck, das ist auch schon seit zehn Jahren bekannt.
Ja, und auch die Prostata seit zehn Jahren, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, genau.
Außerdem habe ich seit drei Jahren einen Wandscheibenvorfall.
Ich muss also immer ein bisschen gucken mit dem Rücken.
Ich habe meinen Rücken schmerzen, aber ich will mich nicht so aufwählen.
Wandscheiben in den Rücken?
Ja, und im linken Auge habe ich grauen Starr.
Da muss ich regelmäßig so Augen tropfen nehmen.
Noch gibt es andere vor Krankungen?
Nach chronischen Krankungen?
Nein, also Blutdruck, Prostata, Wandscheiben.
Und grauer Starr.
Grauer Starr im linken Auge.
Deshalb muss ich grauen Tropfen.
Im linken Auge, ja.
Seit wann?
Ach, dann hat man das festgestellt, ist noch nicht so lange her.
Vielleicht so anderthalb, zwei Jahre.
Und was nehmen Sie mit der Gegend?
Ich nehme einmal, nehme ich etwas wegen der Prostata, wie das heißt, weiß ich aber nicht.
Dann habe ich auch Augen tropfen, den Namen weiß ich auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich aber noch ein Medikament, das heißt, Kongor 50.
Und da nehme ich immer morgens eine, die ist glaube ich für den Blutdruck.
Kongor?
Kongor.
50 Milligramm.
Ja.
Und gegen Blutdruck nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Ich dachte, das kommt wohl gegen den Blutdruck.
Das ist gut.
Und Prostata, Sie wissen nicht, welcher Medikament ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, dass ich es nicht mehr will.
Unser grauer Starr.
Vor dem grauen Starr, auch Sie wissen, Sie nehmen keine Medikamente.
Wie die Augen tropfen, heißt nicht.
Die Augen tropfen stehen bei mir auf dem Badezimmer, aber wie die heißen weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Herr Simon, haben Sie bemerkt, in der letzten Zeit,
dass Ihre Gewicht verändert, zum Beispiel Sonne oder Abnahme?
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ja, ich habe das gemerkt.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass meine Hosen mir alle runterrutschen.
Ja, ich habe 6 Kilo abgenommen.
6 Kilo abgenommen.
Ja.
In welcher Zeit, Frau?
Ja, ich denke, seit dem Frühjahr.
In ungefähr?
Ja, so ein halbes Jahr.
Halbes Jahr.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Schlucken?
Schlucken selber?
Nein, Schlucken geht.
Okay.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, Schwörungen im Haus oder im Achil?
Achil.
Achil hohe.
Ja, ich bin allergisch auf Iod.
Und auf Nauvalgin bin ich auch allergisch.
Das darf ich auch nicht.
Und Verzweglichkeit?
Einig, kann ich alles essen?
Ich wusste gar nicht, kann alles essen hier?
Ja, das ist gut.
Und ich weiß nicht, Sie sind 74 Jahre alt.
Aber ich muss,
ich muss sagen, dass ich in der Corona-Krise,
vielleicht Sie erinnern sich,
für die Impfstatus sind Sie gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Kinderkrankheiten bestimmt.
Und ich weiß sicher, dass ich gegen Corona-Gemäß bin.
Ja, wie viel mal?
3 mal.
Waren Sie im Ausland in letzter Zeit?
Nein.
Okay.
Leben noch?
Eltern?
Das wäre ein Wunder, wenn die noch leben würden.
Vielleicht schon lange tot.
Ja, die sind natürlich schon lange tot.
Mein Vater war so alt wie ich jetzt.
Da ist er gestorben, am Herz in Fakt.
Und meine Mutter hatte Brustkrebs.
Und ist mit 72 gestorben.
Brustkrebs.
Sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Simon?
Ich bin verwidert.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben 3 Töchter.
Wir sind aber natürlich sehr alt.
Und sind Sie gesungen?
Die sind zu viel.
Ich weiß, alle sind gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich sind Sie Renter.
Jetzt bin ich Renter, ja.
Was waren Sie vom Büro?
Ich bin Busgefahrer.
Ich war Busfahrer.
Ja, wichtiger Büro.
Mein Sohn musste Bus-Engineer sein.
Mechanische-Engineer, aber ich musste nur Busstellen.
Er hat mir gesagt, ich möchte das für diese Rollstuhl.
Automatische Rollstuhl.
Das war ein sehr guter Bus.
Ich habe mich dann auch mitgegeben.
Ich habe mich dann mitgegeben.
Automatisch zu machen.
Ich musste Busfahrer aufnehmen.
Ich habe mich dann mitgegeben.
Haben Sie Stress?
Ich bin Renter.
Ich habe keinen Stress.
Ich habe mich dann mitgegeben.
Ich habe keine Stress.
Wir haben keinen Stress.
Ich habe die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Müssten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie eine Frage?
Ich will wissen, was man dagegen machen kann.
Ich will wissen, ob das Schlimmes ist.
Ich kann nicht genau wissen.
Ich habe keine Frage.
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber auf jeden Fall haben Sie Probleme in der Lunge.
Und die Branche um Atemwegen.
Und dafür brauchen Sie Korbischen.
Blutabnahmen und weitere operative Untersuchungen.
Was ist eine operative Untersuchung?
Ja.
Als erste Schritt.
Rungen.
Bild.
Ja.
Und wir geben fast.
Computer Tomografie.
Und aber das ist früher zu sagen.
Aber vielleicht auch Sie brauchen.
Vielleicht Sie könnten Bronkoskopie brauchen.
Was ist eine Branche-Moskopie?
Das klingt gefährlich.
Na ja, es ist ein Bildgeber.
Geber-Untersuchung.
Mit, was wir sagen, das ist ein Bildgeber.
Das ist ein Bildgeber.
Was wir sagen, das ist ein Bildgeber.
Ich habe vergessen, die durch den Mund.
Und die Atemrohre.
Atemrohre.
Luftrohre sagen wir.
Luftrohre.
Ja, mit einem flexibel Schlag.
Ein flexibel schlauchartiges.
Untersuchung gerät.
Das ist ein Diskop.
Ja.
Und bei Bildschirm.
Wir können die.
Atemwegen.
Schauen.
Und eventuell.
Ja.
Wir können die.
Erkrankungen ausschließen.
Oder beurteilen.
Und eventuell.
Wir können ein Gewehr benehmen.
Ja, das tut doch sicherlich weh.
Kriege ich da eine?
Ja, ja, das tut weh.
Ja, das tut gut.
Aber das machen wir nicht heute.
Nein, nein, nicht heute.
Zuerst machen wir Corbisch-Untersuchung.
Blutabnahme.
Röngen.
Und dann.
Okay.
Ich habe ein Kollege in der Frage.
Eine.
Ich habe eine Frau.
Früher habe ich mal viele Zigaretten geraucht.
Aber jetzt seit ich im Rohestand bin.
Rauch ich nur.
Ein bis zweimal am Tag eine Pfeife.
Aber früher, als ich Bus gefahren bin.
In der Zeit habe ich viel geraucht.
Da habe ich 30 Stück am Tag geraucht.
30 Stücke.
Und dann.
Welche Zeit.
Das.
Die ganze Zeit.
Ich war 40 Jahre.
40 Jahre.
Und seit wann haben Sie auf.
Gehören.
Ja, jetzt rauch ich nur noch Pfeife.
Wie gesagt.
Sie schon.
Sie noch rauchen.
Aber 50.
Aber nur ein bis zwei Pfeifen am Tag.
Meistens am Abend.
Ein, zwei.
Und Sie.
Okay.
Erinnerung.
Sie sind seit wann.
Sie haben mit 30.
Zigaretten aufgehören.
Oder.
Ja.
Als ich in Rente gegangen bin.
Also vor zehn Jahren.
Zehn Jahre.
Was bedeutet, Sie brauchen eine.
Zwei Zigaretten Bruder.
Seit zehn Jahren.
Eine Zigaretten, sondern Pfeife.
Hab Pfeife.
Ja.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, was ist das.
Das ist.
Mani Tabakreinstuft.
Ja, und das.
Das ist ein Stück.
Da kommt der Tabakfonds ein.
Wie viel Zigaretten das entspricht?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich denke vielleicht doppelt so viel.
Aber wie das umgerechnet wird, weiß ich nicht.
Aber meistens ist das so.
Dass man Pfeife nicht auf Lohne raucht.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Und drücken Sie Alkohol?
Also Arseneflasche Bier,
aber sonst eigentlich kein Pfeife.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie das.
Aber Arseneflasche Bier, aber sonst eigentlich kein Alkohol.
Arseneflasche Bier.
Herr Zimmer, nehmen Sie bitte diese Frage.
Besonders.
Das ist einfach Routine.
Frage.
Nehmen Sie alle Drogen oder haben Sie.
Hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen.
Ich in meinem Alter.
Nein, ich habe nie etwas mit Drogen zu tun.
Nein.
Ja, okay.
Okay, okay.
Danke schön.
Vorob.
Sind Sie einmal operiert worden?
Ja, er ist operiert worden.
Und zwar.
Als Kind hatte er den Blind am Raus bekommen.
Dann hatte er vor 20 Jahren.
Ne geilen Blasen.
Und vor 10 Jahren.
Eine erste Bandschreiben.
Okay.
Was hat er für den Blasen OP gehabt?
Und vor 10 Jahren.
Eine erste Bandschreiben.
Okay.
Vor 10 Jahren.
Was?
Bandschreiben.
Und jetzt hat er ja seit 3 Jahren.
Ein neuen Bandschreiben Vorfall.
Aber den will er nicht operieren lassen.
Okay.
Als Kind waren Blind am Entfernung.
Geilblasen vor 20 Jahren.
Ja.
Geilblasen.
Vor 20 Jahren.
Ja.
Und Bandschreiben.
Vor 10 Jahren.
14 Jahre. Noch andere Fragen? Wir müssen eine wichtige Frage nach Schweiß nicht gefragt.
Hat er gefragt? Doch, nach Schweiß hat er gefragt.
Haben Sie nach Schweiß? Nein, hatte nicht.
Danke schön. Können wir anfangen?
Ja, ich würde Ihnen eine kleine Pause, dass immer eben krank zusammenkommen.
Ja, für die Frau.
Ja, okay.
Ja, okay, danke.
Guten Abend, Frau Oberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne den neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich? Ja, natürlich.
Ja, sein Name ist Manfred Simon.
Er ist 74 Jahre alt und zwar geboren am 25. April 1948.
Er ist 1,78 m groß und wiegt 89 kg.
Herr Simon stellte sich bei uns heute Morgen
wegen seit 3 Monaten starke Hüste
mit blutiger Auswurf.
Die Farbe weiß nicht.
Der Patient bericht, dass die Schmerzen seit lange Zeit
einige Jahre bestätigen sein.
Aber seit 3 Monaten sind immer schlechter, stärker geworden.
Die Schmerzen oder die Husten? Die Husten.
Der Patient klagte auf, dass er beim Husten Schmerzen habe.
Die Schmerzintensität sei 5 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Er benutzte zwei Histen bei Schlafen.
Der Patient klagte über 6 kg in 6 Monaten.
Die Frage nach Fieber, Schuttelwurst und nach Schweiß
wurden verneint.
Er klagte, dass bei Aufsteigen
die Schmerzen und die Schmerzen nicht verneint.
Im Treppensteigen, die Schmerzen und die Schmerzen nicht verneint.
Die Frage nach Schweiß, Schmerzen und nach Schweiß
wurden verneint.
Er hat eine Neukonfektorie.
Der Patient und alle Anforderungen sind bekannt.
Er hat eine Artrielle Hepatounie seit 10 Jahren.
Er prostet Hepatrophie seit auch 10 Jahren.
Er ist aus der Schmerz- und Schmerz-Bahn.
Er ist aus der Schmerz-Bahn.
Galblase, Entfernung, und vor zehn Jahren Ben Scheibe, auch in des Diskusprolaps OP.
Herr Simon folgen die Medikamente ein.
Ein Medikament Contro, 50 Milligramm, eine Tropfen, aber er weiß nicht,
der Dynamik und die Osierung.
Er klagte, dass er Jude Allergie und Neuwaldin haben.
Allergie gegen Jude und Neuwaldin.
Die Frage nach Unverzweglichkeit wurde verneint.
Die Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Er ist zwei Mal, drei Mal gegen COVID-19 geimpft.
Herr Simon war starker Raucher.
Er war ungefähr 30 Tage täglich vor 40 Jahren.
Zurzeit, seit ungefähr zehn Jahren, er raucht ein, zwei Pfeife.
Alkohol, ein Flasch Bier, ein Drückenkonstant, wurde verneint.
Ein Flasch Bier pro Tag.
Ja, täglich.
Herr Simon, er geht, dass ihre beiden Eltern gestorben sind.
Der Vater ist am Herst im Pfad verstorben
und die Mutter nach Brustkrebs verstorben.
Herr Simon ist für Pfeife und hat drei gesunde Tochter.
Er lebt allein.
Er ist Rente, aber früher arbeitete als Busfahrer.
Er hat keine Stress.
Das war von meiner Seite.
Was ist Ihre Vermutung?
Woher gehen Sie denn aus?
Auf einer nöstischen Angebung gehe ich am ehesten von Bronschale-Karzinon aus.
Das könnte es noch sein.
Das ist am ehesten, weil der Patient hat viele Angebungen und hat Risikofaktoren.
Ich wollte die Differenzialdiagnosen von Ihnen.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen in Betracht Pneumonie, Herzinsuffizienz, Tibi, Tuberkulosa.
Und weitere lungentumoren.
Was machen Sie denn noch mit den Patienten?
Ja, für weitere Erklärungen empfehle ich folgende Massnahmen.
Wie hoch achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Auskultation.
Inspektion auch.
Wir hören die Atemgeräusche.
Bei Tumoren gibt es keine normale Geräusche.
Was schlafen Sie denn untersuchen im Labor?
Im Labor Entschuldung, Parameter, Pneumonie auszuschließen.
Z.B. z.B. z.B. z.B. z.B. z.B. z.B. Zerreaktivprotein, Blut, Sgmentation, Geschwindigkeit, Zahllopozitin usw.
Was machen Sie noch?
Vielleicht habe ich etwas überhört.
Ich habe hier noch die Tumomaker auf dem Zettel.
Das ist auch wichtig.
Wir machen auch eine TB-Auszuschließen-Tuberkulin-Test.
Was machen Sie dann?
Ich habe die TB-Auszuschließen-Test.
Wir haben die TB-Auszuschließen-Test.
Wir können die TB-Auszuschließen-Test machen.
Wir haben auch die TB-Auszuschließen-Test.
Wir haben die TB-Auszuschließen-Test.
Man kann schon sehr viele auf dem Röckenbild sehen.
Dann werden wir mit der Obst-Biopsy-Biopsy durchführen.
Das ist auch noch diagnostisch.
Ich habe noch die Diagnostik verstanden.
Was wäre die Therapie?
Ich sollte meine Verdacht von der Prinzel-Krebs-Prinzessin bestätigen.
Ich schlage die folgenden Massnahmen.
Ich habe eine stazionäre Behandlung.
Ich gebe Oxygen und Sauerstoff.
Ich gebe Antitrusiven und Antravenous-Flüssigkeit.
Der Patient hat keine Entzündung-Symptome.
Was machen Sie gegen den Krebs?
Krebs, wir machen ein ökologisches Konzil.
Wenn möglich, ist eine operative Behandlung.
Sonst palliativ mit Ausstrahlung.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Das ist sicherlich gut, wenn der ein paar Tage stationär war.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, war sprachlich.
Als ich nach der Brontioskopie gefragt habe,
war ich als Patient.
Das war etwas Neues.
Ich bin für die Überraschung gut.
Natürlich war das Arztgespräch nicht so glatt.
Es fehlt wieder am Ende.
Herr Siemer stellte sich vor.
Ich warne jedes Mal wieder vor diesem Schreck.
Wenn man so viele Sachen nach ein paar weiß man nicht mehr.
Das machen Sie gut.
Sie sagen, folgende Vorerkrankungen sind bekannt.
Das ist ein guter Trick.
Sie haben ihre Prüfung?
Sie haben eine Sorge.
Sprachlich sind Sie sicher.
Sie haben nicht alle selber Husten reizt.
Sie haben eine halbe Stunde zuhören.
Sie haben eine Sorge.
Ich verabschiede mich von Ihnen allen.
Ich habe das letzte Mal am Dienstag um 19 Uhr getroffen.
Wir sehen uns am Dienstag.
Tschüss.